okay uh
a very warm welcome to all of you
to this session so today uh we are going
to
discuss genomics what is genomics data
how it is organized
and how it is interpreted
to to be such a powerful resource in the
hands of clinicians researchers and
entrepreneurs and how reading the dna
code will help us battle cancer will
help us fight off infectious diseases
and will help us even solve some crimes
so let's start by reviewing the
fundamentals of genomics so genomics is
all about dna so let's review what is
dna code so what do we
what do we already know about this and
what kind of answers can we find here
how can we analyze huge sequences of
nucleotides stored in the dna and how do
we make sense of them
just like a book the dna code is
organized as letters that form sentences
and sentences that form paragraphs and
paragraphs that form
that are organized into
chapters knowing how to read this code
can help us decipher the full story
about who we are and to look into our
history and to understand how we are
connected to other living things around
us so dna is
short for
deoxyribonucleic acid so it's a long
molecule composed of two chains that
coil around each other to form a double
helix this double helix carries genetic
instruction for development for function
for growth and reproduction of all known
life so this all this includes this all
known life includes multi and single
cell organisms and as well as many
bacteria and even some viruses so
yeah so the dna code contains directions
or recipes for life including the
capacity to grow including the capacity
to reproduce and including functional
activity that characterizes the cells
and including the continuous change that
proceeds until the cell is
uh cell deaths dies off
since life is a condition that
distinguishes animals from plants
animals and plants from inorganic matter
understanding this dna code is
synonymous to understanding life itself
so
the instruction for life of a single
cell under and also a life of a complex
organisms like us uh humans which
contains over 37 trillion cells right
each cell contains the same dna which is
stored in a
nucleus
when cells divide
as they do when new organisms is formed
are uh
when used cells has to be generated we
see how this dna is organized the
nucleus is opened up inside we discover
these tightly packed strings that
can be visible under a microscope these
are chromosomes chromosomes contains
different genes each one of our cells
contain 23 pairs of chromosomes one
chromos one of them or one of the
chromosomes come from uh one half of the
chromosomes come from our mother the
other half comes from our father
yes so unique
this unique structure of chromosomes
keeps dna tightly wrapped around in a
spool uh trapped around around proteins
like a spool and these proteins are
histones so with without such packaging
into tightly wound
chromosomes dna molecules would be
extremely long to fit inside the cell
for example if all of the dna molecules
inside a single human cell were to be
unwound from their histones and to be
placed as end to end as a single stretch
a single string that would stretch
to
reach to six feet so the largest
chromosomes uh chromosome of all the
chromosomes is chromosome one which
contains about eight thousand genes and
the smallest chromosome is chromosome 21
which contains about 300 genes so once
the cell division is complete the
information on the cell that is stored
in the dna helps the new cell
know what to do to continue its function
that it will work on for the rest of its
life and preserve the dna that it has
been passed on from its parents and to
pass on to the next cell and in the
meantime the dna that contains
instruction for various functions in a
cell must perform to grow and maintain
life and function therefore the dna
contains both
both the necessary ingredients like
all the recipes that is required for the
cell to function and all the other
instructions that is required for the
dna to be stored and accessed at the
specific time together all of the
specific code of chromosomes that we are
dealing with or that we are discussing
with is called a genotype the product of
this code and how it interacts with the
environment is called a phenotype a
phenotype can describe a single cell a
tissue
an organ or even the whole organism a
phenotype of an organism could include
height size weight or activity
and phenotype of a cell could include
its specific function its size its shape
or morphology and
its composition so
dna is made up of
nucleotides at the basic level at the
base it's a fundamental level the dna is
made up of nucleotides a nucleotide is
made up of a sugar called deoxyribose
and a nitrogen containing base and a
phosphate group so the nucleotides are
joined to one another in a chain by
covalent bond that forms between sugar
of one nucleotide and the phosphate of
the next resulting in an alternative
sugar phosphate sugar phosphate backbone
so each strand of a dna molecule
consists of a sequence of bases that is
complementary to the basis in the
opposing strand so the pairing between
these complementary bases is what gives
rise to the characteristics double helix
shape so in this structure adenine is
bound to thiamine and guanine is bound
to cytosine so to understand how dna
works and to read its sequence a special
project was aimed at decoding dna
that was launched in 1990 so this
13-year long project was initiated in
1990 and is focused on determining the
dna sequence of the entire human genome
so scientists set out to determine the
dna sequence and the location of
estimated uh
100 000 human genes at the time of it at
the time of the initiation of this
project
many at that time believed that once we
had the sequence we would quickly be
able to determine where all the genes
were
and this process of reading the dna
sequences and piecing them together
found
laid the foundation of what we are
doing today led the foundation for
genomic study and
the foundation for all the other omics
study that is thriving today
yeah
so but simply reading the code and
annotating it uh
became a much longer process than the
than sequencing the genome itself and
the human genome
project itself today there are several
different competing human gene databases
with many thousands of differences among
them although the number of protein
coding genes has gradually converged and
the number of other gene types has
exploded so the the latest count has
found over uh consistently has found
over 22 000 genes long since the human
genome project was completed so we have
around 22 000 genes
yeah
protein chlorine genes and that forms
only one to two percentage of
content that we have in our
whole genome so
so in brief the dna is stored in the
nucleus and it is organized into
chromosomes and into specific g regions
and some of these regions are easier to
read and to access and to be evaluated
for uh for
for the functions and these easy to read
from easy to read uh regions are called
protein coding genes and protein coding
genes are the sequences or the
genes or sequences that is used to
produce proteins so how it is done it
the central dogma of molecular biology
describes how this is done this is done
involving a two-step process
transcription and translation by which
the information from the gene is is
converted first into rna and then to
protein the information flows from genes
to proteins through dna being converted
to rna and rna being translated to
protein so in each step of this
transformation we see how the dna code
is used first for transcribing the
source code to a working repository of
rna where some code is modified and some
code is not used at all and then it is
released for producing a functional
product called protein so this process
is
has facilitated
several key proteins one of which is
called is processes facilitated by
several key proteins so one of which is
called dna polymerase this dna
polymerase is a one which attaches to
the dna
as it unzips to replicate the dna to
form single strand
to single strand and
and then it adds complementary bases to
the single strand and creating a second
workable copy this copied dna code can
in principle be used in other cells also
but
but
yeah
it is yeah can be used in other cells
also but it is also important to make
sure such a replication process goes
without any mistake so that
the cell doesn't end up with uh with a
different set of uh copy copied dna than
to the original set and the cell also
has a lot of mechanisms and other
products and instrumentation in protein
complexes that are designed to prevent
this error or in error correction
mechanisms also so
each gene
as we saw
is a recipe for certain protein so the
gene sequences encodes instruction from
which a protein can be made and
the dna sequences encodes the
instruction from which the protein can
be made so proteins are the products of
amino acids which are encoded by the
three uh sequences are try nucleotide
sequences that are called codons that
are stored in the dna so the dna
sequences in
they are read
read by the jump of three first three uh
three uh sequences are read and then
converted into one amino acid and then
it goes the next three and then goes the
next three so a codon is a sequence of
three nucleotides that corresponds to
specific amino acid or a stop signal
during a protein synthesis process once
a right place on dna is copied over it
is prepared for translation by forming a
messenger rna that is exported from the
nucleus so the translation happens uh in
the
cytosol not in the nucleus so in humans
we saw genes are very important and they
make up protein
and in human genes vary in sizes from
few hundred dna bases to more than two
million
dna bases or two million nucleotides the
keratin associated protein for example
is 447 nucleotide long but whereas
cntnap2 gene has something like
more than
more than 200 yeah more than 2 million
nucleotides so the number of genes also
varies between various organisms for
example the influenza virus has only 11
genes while the grape genome has over 30
000 genes so
the information is not uniform across
the different organisms neither the
information about coding proteins is
uniform across the genome itself so the
genes are not just sequences of
nucleotides in fact they have regulatory
sequences at both the ends of the genes
that is upstream and also downstream
this regulatory sequences controls the
level of transcription of each gene so
inside the gene sequence itself there
are protein coding regions called codons
or exons and non-coding regions called
introns the cells machinery perform a
process called splicing that will leave
out or that will exclude the introns and
then include only the exons before the
gene is translated into proteins and the
extraordinary length of some of the
genes has enabled the presence of
introns and this
presence of introns and multiple introns
provides a mechanism for generation of
transcriptional diversity through
alternative combinations of different
exons at different levels
so the translation in the cell is done
by a ribosome which can read the mrna
sequence and assemble the protein and
this protein can be
can then fold into a functional form or
functional structure so
can you see my yeah i think yes now it
is working yeah so when we want to
understand the function of a particular
protein we typically combine the
information about its chromosome
position about the coding sequences that
it has about the regulatory region about
the structure as well as functional
features of the protein and about
all these information which are
understood through thorough experimental
validation and
or its comparison to proteins from the
same family or proteins that has the
same structure so now we understood the
context of what is dna how it is
organized and how it is used and how it
is
translated to form protein which are the
machinery uh that uh defines the
characteristics or that defines a
phenotype of the cell or that defines
the functions of the cell so let's
discuss how to analyze this dna code
let's look at the sequence alignment and
identification of variant that have
functional consequences on the phenotype
of the biological system currently under
study
so let's go back to a little bit of a
history so the year 2020 marks a 70-year
mark since the discovery of a structure
and function of dna molecules it took
almost 50 years from the time
to sequence the first human genome but
soon after the technology evolved and
exploded rapidly and by 2050 we have the
1000 genome project which brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018
we have over 100 000 whole genomes that
that were sequenced and today this is an
ever increasing number of uh there is an
ever increasing number of different
omics datasets that are available that
will describe cellular and subcellular
process in a detail that is that that
cannot be imagined uh something like 50
years ago
so
the oh makes the multiple omics that we
just that you just heard aims at a
collective characterization and
quantification of pools of biological
molecules that translates into structure
function and dynamics of this organism
on multiple organisms the ohmic
technologies are used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of
various types of molecules that make up
the cells open organisms many types of
omics data that can be generated using
high throughput sequencing or negligence
sequencing can show detailed information
about genomic variants epigenomic
regulation phenomic data types and
the different transcriptomic states of
the uh
cells that we have in our study
the suffix ohm one used to define
various field actually originated uh
from um
in the 20th century
in the 20th
in the 20th century when genome was
first coined in germany in the beginning
of uh yeah in the in the 20th century
the word genomics refers to the totality
of the genomes or the study of all the
gene all the genes of genomes that is
present in the
cell a genome is an organism's complete
set of dna including all of the gene as
i mentioned in contrast to genetics
which specifically refers to study of
individual genes and their role in
inheritance and
and their characteristics that defined
from this inheritance genomics aims at
the collective characterization and
quantification of all the organisms
genes their interrelations and influence
on their organisms
as a result of such effort we can now
detect differences which can be harmless
or differences that will lead to serious
issue when a gene is produced so just
like any code we can expect the dna code
to contain mistakes so these mistakes
occur as a result of copying the dna
source too many times as a result of or
as a result of various stresses that can
interfere with the with this copying
mechanism that
that is inside the cell
so to understand how genomics is used we
need to understand the analysis
approaches to
dna codes specifically how we can
identify the changes or how we can
identify the mutations that characterize
them and to interpret the significance
of these changes that we uh naturally
observe or that we observe when we um
when we sequence the
dna so mutation can actually happen in
several different ways so one form is
substitution a substitution mutation is
is something that can cause
several consequences to dna code but it
implies a minimal change that only leads
to a single nucleotide change so when
one nucleotide is substituted with the
other nucleotide it's a straightforward
substitution an insertion changes
insertion however changes the number of
dna bases in a gene by adding a piece of
dna as a result the protein that is made
by the gene may not function properly
because the reading sequences have
completely changed due to the insertion
of this one or multiple dna bases
a deletion mutation however changes the
number by removing one or certain pieces
of dna small deletions may remove one or
few basis within a gene while larger lip
deletions can involve removing an entire
gene or entire exon
dna sequence may alter the function com
completely uh
completely
alter the function of the resulting
protein and that is going to interfere
with the cells processes so a
duplication mutation or duplication even
consists of a piece of dna that is
abnormally copied one or more times this
type of mutation also alters the
function of the resulting proteins and
which will also interfere with the cells
machinery so
a specific type of variation can lead to
harmful
results for example a change in function
is harmful and this is called uh yeah
this is called mutation or in the other
way uh when when the changes in these uh
variation is not uh is not harmful then
that will that will not be uh yeah that
that is not a
um
that's a neutral mutation or that is no
mutation yeah
yeah that is a variation so for example
in this case uh
variation causes the eye color to change
while
mutation causes
some really horrible deformities and
functional losses
so when
when these genomic variants are
discussed both mutation and
both the term mutation and polymorphisms
are used interchangeably but
by convention
by convention in human genetic research
any genomic variant
with the population frequency of less
than one percentage is termed as
mutation
while
any genomic variant with the frequency
of greater than one percentage is termed
as polymorphism so this distinction
based on the population frequency uh
based on the population frequency of the
variant rather than the type of the
variant is uh
is based on the variant of the type
rather than the type of variant or its
possible functional impact however as a
rule rare mutations that are rare that
is even less than one percent uh um
observations tend to have functional
impact that deviates from the wild type
a yield to higher
higher yeah yield to higher signal to
noise ratio for detection of a genetic
influence of a trait or a rare mutation
that will have functional impact
can have
very drastic effects in the uh
in the uh yeah influence of the trait in
contrast polymorphisms that is observed
tend to result in less functionally
deviant genomic variants it will not uh
it might not uh however it might not
cause
severe deformities or severe
functional
impact of the cells or of the organisms
in study so uh
yeah however it is also worthwhile to
think or it is also worthwhile to keep
in mind that these rules uh there are
exceptions to these rules it is also
observed that polymorphisms can be some
of the specific polymorphisms can be
involved
loss of function and some of the
simple variations in
in gene mutation
can lead to
no losses function at all so
so a single nucleotide mutations can be
of several kinds so this is a single uh
nucleotide mutations uh substitution
mutations can be of several kind one of
this kind is mis sense mutation which is
which changes only one dna base pair and
that results in a substitution of one
amino acid for the other in the protein
made by the gene a nonsense mutation
however changes one dna base that
prematurely causes the cell uh causes
the
cell to stop building the protein or the
it introduces a stop codon in the dna
sequence that
prematurely stops the length of the
protein
that is being synthesized and this type
of mutation
results in a shortened protein which
will not or which might not function
properly at all there is another type of
mutation which is a frame shift mutation
where an addition or a deletion of dna
bases completely changes the frame of
the
genes reading
as i had introduced you before the
codons are read three basis once so when
you delete or insert one or few bases
this reading frame changes and by
reading by changing this reading frame
frame shift mutation occurs and this
will result in a protein that is
completely different from the original
or completely different from the wild
type protein and this could usually
be result in a non-functional protein so
to summarize these different genomic
variations
genomic variations can be of several
different types so when when analyzing
the genomic variance or genomic data we
are looking to find and characterize
this changes in the dna code and
associate such changes that we are
either observing to the phenotype or to
the different cells characteristics here
are some of the acronyms and some of the
words and jargons that you have to
remember
about genomic variations snps and smbs
so snv is a single nucleotide variant
where
a single nucleotide change that may or
may not be present in the population
basically this means any change from the
reference genome that we find in a given
dna sequence above the
level of technical error so snp is a on
the other hand is a single nucleotide
polymorphism where a nucleotide is known
to be altered in a proportion of
population and typically considered to
be prevalent in approximately ah more
than one percentage of the population so
this is a pop single nucleotide
polymorphism uh is the
is a mechanism that causes blue eyes and
green eyes and different eye colors in
the uh in our in our in different human
races so
another form of acronym that you should
remember is copy number variation where
the same gene is that is encoded or same
gene is being copied multiple times and
is present in
different number of copies across
different cell types or occurs different
conditions of the
cells that is under study so such
changes uh
involves a such changes
as well as the characteristics of these
different variants are commonly
referred to as genotype of the cell or
genotype of the organisms so this is
what we are studying by
understanding or by sequencing the dna
sequence and by trying to analyze the
dna sequence we are trying to understand
the genotype of the organisms or we are
trying to understand the genotype of the
cells so
the bioinformatics technology that will
allow you to generate the digital
information from these biological
samples is called a next-gen sequencing
or high-throughput sequencing this
technology was first developed during
the human genome human genome project as
as discussed ago and has evolved
tremendously since then so over the
years many different sequencing
techniques were introduced and they were
developed and perfected to study whole
genome sequences of the of multiple
organisms those sequencing platforms use
variety of variety of read lengths so
read lengths is the length of the
dna sequence that can be read at once
and this
this varies by different sequencing
platforms there are but in general they
can be
divided into short read sequences and
long read sequencers so the benefit of
the short read sequences isn't that
because they are short but they can be
extremely inexpensive and they can be
generated in a massively parallel manner
with billions and billions of uh reads
being generated in a single run so uh
the cost
when the cost needs to be kept down and
then you have to sequence multiple
different samples and and you have to
perform a lot of times
and the read count has to be really high
and then short read technologies makes
most sense while long reads on the other
hand can resolve regions of genome that
are inaccessible or that are inherently
not possible to assemble due to the
length of the short reads
because these regions can involve repeat
sequences and those repeat sequences
uh may have maybe uh
those repeat sequences may um
interrupt our uh read mapping process so
um so in that case long read sequences
have advantages over short range
sequences
while dealing specifically with those
regions which have repeat sequences and
latest advancements in recent
advancements made by oxford nanopart
technologies for example under right
conditions under perfect conditions
under perfect high quality dna can even
produce reads up to 1 million bases that
is huge so
this technology allows researchers to
explore the genetic variations like
never before down to a single nucleotide
resolution whether you need to identify
specific variants that
from a focused set of regions or to look
more broadly about potential
different variations or causative
variations or to look for um yeah or to
look for uh differences or variations in
uh in the number of uh number of
variations in uh in the number of times
a gene is being copied so these are all
different
explorations that one can perform so
based on this whole exome sequencing or
whole genome sequencing can both offer
effective solutions based on your
question to what to look for and how to
design your data
whole exome sequencing or whole genome
sequencing as i mentioned can be both
effective so whole exome sequencing is a
targeted
method to
sequence all protein coding regions in
the genome it offers reliable and
sensitive detections of coding variants
and it is fast and it is cost effective
as it sequences only a fraction of what
the whole genome sequencing is going to
perform whole genome sequencing on the
other hand provides a comprehensive view
of the genome including coding
non-coding mitochondrial dna and
everything that is present in the cell
so it is reliable and sensitive as well
but in but includes but yeah it is it is
the process is uh
complicated and it also uh it can
provide you
with the necessary information about uh
detection of
different variant types that is under
study or that is under question and
these variant types are these variations
and mutations uh these variations are
not
limited to
coding regions
alone because we are sequencing the
whole genome um
yeah
so now let's uh understand about how
this process is being employed and how
this has been done in a very very short
intro so the ngs technology that
captures uh
the ngs technology that sequences the
dna basis actually captures and
generates
this digital data using several steps
here the whole genomic dna is isolated
and then it is sheared and it is
shattered and sheared and placed in a
flow cell so inside the flow cell the
dna fragments are amplified using bridge
pcr amplification and then the flow cell
is inserted into the sequencer the
sequencer machine uses image analysis to
capture each and every nucleotide in
this flow cell fragments by analyzing
the visual
patterns and converting them into
sequence of letters that is tcga that
are the nucleotides that forms the basis
eventually the sequencer will produce
reads typically of 30 to 300 base pairs
base pairs in length so this sequencing
data that is emerging or that is coming
out of the sequencer is stored in
several different file formats so for
example a fastq file format will provide
us reads with both
will provides provide us the reads from
the sequencer and it is text-based file
format this stores the nucleotide
sequences of reads and the quality
scores for each letter that is sequenced
the fasta format
on the other hand stores the
representing dna and protein sequences
and this is typically uh reserved for
the reference file of the genome or
reference file for the genome to which
the reads that are in first q files are
matched to then we have the genome
transfer format which contains the
genome annotation for example a genome
transfer form a gtf file will store the
start and end of each genomic element
like exon like isoform are like gene and
and other sequences uh other elements
that you find in the whole genome
sequence so uh
so in
if
can somebody mute their
microphone please
yeah so in short a faster file contains
a genomic sequence itself with um
with the line that starting as a with a
with the line that starts with the
greater than symbol which uh which is a
header that uh describes a sequence and
this is uh and describe the sequence uh
um
for example this header describes a
species from which the sequence is uh
for from which for which the dna
sequence belongs to
in this case it's from a virus in this
case it's from a
frugal part of fungus
so a fastq file on the other hand is
also a text based format but it's stored
the sequence and it also stores the
corresponding quality scores of each and
every
letter that is being sequenced so both
the sequence both the sequence letter
quality scores of each re
are encoded in a single ascii character
so a fastq file normally includes
information about the name of the read
its length the raw sequence letters and
the quality values for each sequence for
each nucleotide depending upon this
sequencing method that has been employed
fastq files can be quite large sometimes
over several gigabytes in size per file
so to analyze such
raw data
many different tools for genomic data
analysis are used these analysis tools
include alignment of reads and full full
sequences analysis of relationship
between sequence and their evolutionary
divergence and measurements of gene
expression and relationship between
sequences and structures as well as a
relationship between somatic and
germline variant calling methods and
multiple different techniques that will
characterize somatic and germline
variants so the platform the tbio info
platform
yeah the tbio info is a big data
platform that can be used to perform all
of these analysis and many other using
an intuitively user friendly interface
so the sequence alignment that i
mentioned ago can refer to two types of
alignment the sequence alignment to a
reference in which case it is called
mapping so where you have the first
queue files and these files are
from the sample and you wish to align
these files or reads to its best
position on the genome to find whether
the sequence in the read or multiple
reads reveal variation from the
reference which are in fast step format
so
another alignment in other type of
alignment which is multiple sequence
alignment this is what you do when you
have multiple consensus sequences that
you would like to compare each one of
these sequences
for their differences or for their
similarities and develop an
understanding between them in terms of
how the sequences or portions of these
sequences are conserved or portions and
sequences are
varied so in many cases uh these
multiple sequence alignments are used to
find structurally important variation
and it can also be uh yeah structurally
important variation in both nucleotides
and also in protein sequences
uh
so
yeah so when we have the first q files
ready from the sequencer and when they
are ready to be analyzed there are
several important steps to be considered
for performing the analysis these steps
include preprocessing mapping variant
calling and annotations so for
for each task you can connect analysis
jobs to a pipeline each one of these
various inputs
a pipeline will have various inputs and
each of these
algorithms in this pipeline will have
multiple outputs and
a pipeline is defined by joining several
algorithms together from where uh the
output of one algorithm
straight away or directly
feeds to the input of the other
algorithm and in t bio info platform
the
outputs at each every step is
is is presented to you and is given to
you and you can
analyze or you can visualize where the
information is changed and how
the information content is built upon
and how the information content is uh
maximized at each step of the uh at each
analysis step of this pipeline so
yeah however yeah to carry out a
genome-wide analysis study for example
we use our researchers use two groups of
participants let's say
people with the database are people with
diseases being studied or people with
without diseases sometimes
this
genome-wide association studies can also
be performed uh to identify certain
variations of
disease or conditions
that we have in hand so what
how is this
how is this performed is when the
researchers obtained dna from each
participants and sequence their whole
genome and if a certain
genetic variations are found to be
significantly more frequent in people
with the disease compared to people
without the disease then these
variations are said to be associated
with the disease so
identifying these associated genetic
variations
can serve as a powerful pointers to
understanding those regions of human
genome where the disease causing problem
resides so the methods that i just
mentioned before
downstream analysis or visualization and
somatic mutations can help us
understand and can help us relate these
genetic variations to these
different uh
to these different regions which might
or which will might be involved in
causing diseases or causing problems so
yeah so in this case it's it's easy to
understand or it's easy to uh observe
that uh chromosome 14 has a higher
mutational rate that is that could be
involved in the
disease causing
state
so
downstream analysis will uh will
actually identify mutations
s p variations and these mutations and s
p variations can be presented in
multiple different ways depending upon
the purpose of analysis and in this case
it can be presented in a tabular format
or it can be presented in a simple
graphical format depending upon
depending upon this
depending upon the kind of report that
you are generating based on the analysis
that you just perform so this this
program is actually designed to
help you learn more about these analysis
methods and their applications in
various project examples so uh
this genomics program will include an
expanded overview of key concepts
principles and examples of genomic data
analysis now i want to invite dr
harpreet to present you with a couple of
demonstrations uh of such analysis which
can be performed in tbio info big data
platform so over to you dr harpreet and
then we will come back for the um
for
how to
briefly talk about how such genomic
studies can be used in